Jeff this question and photo
accompanying it is probably the reason
we made this switch this is incredible
like I'm so excited about this I know
some people like Oh Instagram but they
like get over yourselves let's attack
the gram with your questions um this is
a tremendous question - which makes it
even more interesting the hipster my man
is very simply like what you need to
decide is short-term cash versus
long-term wealth
let me explain my answer to you would be
okay you're making the products you by
the way and I had a big business at the
time but like the way I did Wine Library
TV was all encompassing myself except at
Christmas credit not videotape but there
was no editing the way d-roc it was just
uploading and in theory I could have
done that for an hour but probably not
so big shout out to Mott but you have to
decide if you want to make 30 I don't
know how long it takes you to make one
of your pieces right I would make seven
pieces instead of 13 in a year if I can
live off of that right I would do that
and I would then spend more time on
building my brand because that's really
what an artist is doing the Instagram
stuff you're doing building up your
Pinterest being smart and knowing the
world and now look at all the exposure I
mean I guarantee you I really feel
confident that one person will buy one
of your pieces from the show so you you
knew about me you you moved quit you
comment on my comments Alex hit up a
bunch of people over the last couple
days not that many replied you took the
initiative to do it now you're on the
show right now you've got this exposure
twenty thirty thousand views but you
know now what you do with that is you're
leveraging that and all of a sudden it
becomes supply and demand there are
artists who make one thing you know I'm
sure I'm not very strong in the art
world and either you can help me here a
little bit I mean like but I know what
the answer is there's some artists who
make one piece every couple of years and
that's how they make their whole living
because it's worth a ton of money
because they've got the brand now that
you can go brand direct that's my crush
crush to talk to you so much by the way
a horseshit
literally the blueprint of the current
state of the internet I was like I don't
want to like really go there but like I
was ridiculously right not even kind of
and so we're all living in that world
now great story my agency that
represents mine talent is basically the
agency of what crush it was talking
about and so it's a very simple thing
cash wealth if you decide to make seven
pieces this year and that's enough for
you to live then it makes me happy
because then you can take the rest of
that time instead of thirteen not on all
the numbers but you see where I'm going
to build your brand to engage to put out
content to write a medium post to put up
Instagram photos and that builds up your
supply and demand curve if you're
equally good enough at both if you're
equally good enough at both then the sub
demand will get to a place where you can
start charging more for your pieces to
build up your brand it's very simple
there's been going on forever
independent people have always done that
should you make pieces or should you
open a gallery should you have it should
you go Hut like it's chicken-and-egg the
other thing to debate is can you bring
in somebody at a low cost to do it full
time and help you scale you're the only
one that can answer but guess what I'm
the only one who can answer it right but
India's here to make it quicker for me I
do this show so India is something to
transcribe off of add some grammar asked
me a couple clarification questions and
we've got two of the top four posts on
medium right now so you know it all
depends on how you want to roll I had a
build up to that this is the first time
I've got this kind of infrastructure but
it's just chicken and egg you know cash
flow versus wealth there's two ways to
go about doing it you can make 13 pieces
and then you're making the money on it
that allows you to afford your person in
place where you make seven and you do it
yourself for a while it just depends on
how you want to roll but if you're not
building up your equity you're always
going to be making pieces that are
hundreds of dollars instead of pieces
that are millions of dollars oh crap
wait subscribe I need subscriptions
because I can't push this many right
hooks in social so subscribe